what is going on everybody welcome to
the 12th monte carlo and python tutorial
video
you don't know it but i just recorded
this entire video
uh without recording it so i guess i
didn't record it but anyway
this will be the second time i walk
through this entire video
so uh so in the last video we saw
um at least with our multiple we saw
what kind of
we were with our first example of a
monte carlo simulation
actually giving us a variable and we've
got two different betting strategies we
had one where we just bet the same thing
over and over
which obviously resulted in a loss
because there was a one percent house
edge
and with rolled ice um before we end
this series i can't remember if i
already said this or not uh
i can't remember if i said it when i was
recording or when i wasn't recording but
we will change rolled ice uh for pure 50
50 odds just in case you're playing
something like roulette or something
like that where you really do have 50 50
odds
just a rare scenario now
um one of the more popular strategies
with 50 50
odds is called the
i'm gonna butcher the name probably i'm
gonna guess it's day
to allen bear just to guess it's
spelled day apart d apostrophe alan bert
uh with your english accent or america
accent
anyway with this strategy the way it
works is as follows so say you're what
you're starting wager
is a hundred dollars if you lose
you would then bet two hundred dollars
lose three hundred dollars
win two hundred dollars win 100 lose 200
and so on so you increment it that way
you're not multiplying it you're just
adding
one more increment to the original wager
size
so with that we are we're going to
program our own
day allen bear strategy now again i
already went through this once so i'm a
little ticked off
but here we go so uh
define d a l
and of course same parameters as usual
funds initial wager
and wager count colon
and we're going to go ahead and global
variables that don't exist but we'll
make them
so da underscore busts and global
ba underscore profit so we can measure
this guy
value equals funds to start wager
equals initial underscore wager
uh we're not going to be plotting
anything here current
wager equals one of course we start at
one previous wager
uh this is going to be so we know was it
a winner loss last time
for now we're going to say it was a win
just because you will increment
well really you're not doing anything
you're just you definitely don't want to
increment or de-increment or anything so
um so that's that and
also well never mind we'll get into the
next implication but anyway previous
wager equals a win
and then previous wager amount of course
we need to know what we're adding to so
initial wager for now is where it starts
and now we're ready to begin so
while current wager
is less than or equal to wager count
what do we want to do
if the previous wager
previous wager was a win
then what we want to do is de-increment
right but that said just because we want
to
de-increment every time we have a win
let's say that doesn't mean every time
we would want to do that say like if
you've won so much that you're back to
your initial wager amount
if you de-increment you'd be you know
betting in our case a zero or
actually in everybody's cases a0 so
you want to have a check so what we're
going to say is if
wager equals initial wager
pass else wager minus
equals initial wager okay
so that's how we're going to cover that
now we're going to roll the dicer
assume we roll the dice so roll dice so
if roll dice is true so we won
we want to do value plus equals wager
else we lost value minus equals
wager also if we won there's no need to
edit the win
but if we lost we do need to notify the
system that previous
uh wager is a loss
subsequently if uh if we've gone bust
we're gonna say if value is
uh less than or equal to zero
as usual what do we do we're gonna say d
a busts
plus equals one and we want to
break now we come over underneath this
if statement here and we're gonna run
alif
previous wager
if the previous wager was a loss and
make some space
if the previous wager was a loss
uh wager equals previous
wager amount plus
an ish initial underscore wager so we're
adding one increment to it
um if but uh
if our current value so
we need to have a check so we don't go
into the negatives as we've done with
the other ones so we're gonna say if
value so if the amount of money we have
minus the wager we're intending to wage
um is less than or equal to zero we
can't do that so then we're just going
to say wager equals value so we can't go
into the negatives
now when we're all set there the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to roll the dice again so if we roll the
dice and it is true
value oops not caps value plus equals
the wager and since this was a loss
initially we need to edit that variable
so we're going to say previous
wager equals a win now
else value minus equals
wager and we don't need to notify it
that the previous wager was
lost but we do need to notify what the
previous
wager amount was and that equals
wager and
actually we need to do that again here i
believe if the roll
if we roll dice let's see previous wager
equals when if roll dice value
equals plus equals wager
i think we need to notify the wager
amount on all of these
let's see previous wager amount equals
initial wager
if let's see
so if we win a plus equals wager
i really think we need to update
previous
wager amount equals wager
we need to do this on all of these
really so under the if
dice do that under the else
do that under the if
that and we already did it under the
else
i think we're all set there so now we've
covered everything uh except for if
we've gone bust so we'd say
if value is less than or equal to zero
d a underscore bus plus equals one
break i don't need to play anymore and
finally
uh underneath this alif all right if
alif
we want to do current wager plus
equals one finally at the end of
everything we come
down here and at the end of this entire
strategy
we want to know if value is greater than
funds da underscore profits plus
equals 1 and that's basically everything
now the next question we want to know
however
is we'd like to call this strategy first
of all so let's go ahead and call this
bad boy
uh so i'm gonna paste it up here edit in
what we need
so starting funds initial wager
is waiter size and wager count
here pace okay copy this or actually cut
that
and we'll paste that down here and now
just for debugging purposes i think it
would be wise
to have some print statements in here
um so
so we're sure that this is working as
expected so we'll print
current wager and then wager
and then we'll also print how many funds
we have value
value and then if roll dice
is the case uh print
we won current value
value otherwise we lost
so print we lost
current value
value
and then scrolling down further
uh print
lost the last wager current wager
and we'll say wager and then value
value and then again we'll print here
print we won current
value value
and then here print
we lost current value
value cool let's save that
and i think we're prepared to run so
let's run it
syntax raw we mean syntax
i'm looking at it not seeing it
oh here we go oh print there we go
let's do it again all right
so this one person strategy appears
to have lost some money but not
everything is at 8 200 right now
after 100 wagers let's scroll up current
wager 100 we won
he's still going to wager 100. we lost
he lost he's back to 10
000. we lost the last wager current
wager 200.
we lost we're down to 9 800 then we're
gonna wager 300 we
lose apparently and we're back down to 9
500. lost the last one
so we're gonna wager 400 we won 9900
we're gonna do 300 i'm looking for a
streak of two wins it looks like we have
one down here
so 300 we lost 9 600 okay we're going to
wager 400
9 600 we're back to 10 000. current
wager 300
103 205
110 six and so on okay so it looks like
our day allen bear strategy
is now in full effect and just for kicks
uh let's go ahead and comment out some
of these prints we don't need so many
prints
and eventually we will actually graph
the dale and bear strategy i
suspect it'll look quite a bit like the
doublers
strategy over a long period and that is
part of the point of the day allenberry
strategy is that you want to be able to
play for a
while so your odds kind of do go to
50 50. but just for kicks uh
sample size wager count will do 10 000
wagers and let's say you're wagering 10
instead so hopefully this guy doesn't go
totally broke
the a bus is not oh he went bust
fan families uh let's just go ahead and
i guess define
d a underscore busts
equals 0.0 and really we need to define
all these other variables too
uh da busts and da profits
where are you
i'm so lost right now guys okay we
called it here and then everything else
is
way down there so here's what i want to
do
time
we have time imported okay so da best
and we'll also call da underscore
profits
0.0 let's run it again
at the end i guess we're not actually
saying anything are we so at the very
end
uh i guess we'd want to say
uh current wager plus equals zero
print value
zero zero man all these guys are going
broke
surely something is arrived everybody is
going broke
okay i guess i'll uncomment these out
maybe it's just too many wagers oh you
know what though
uh the problem is they're not probably
the problem is we're not at 50 50 odds
i guess we can watch this guy go broke
that is probably the issue here is this
is a 50 50 betting strategy that is not
good if if you have one percent uh
stacked against you i'm gonna go ahead
and guess that's it
yeah okay so
maybe in the next video what we'll work
on is uh
this poor soul what was the most he ever
had
he actually went up pretty high it was
at like 15 grand for a little bit
and it went down from there we lost like
some she had some serious losing streaks
look at this lost
sauce man you'd be getting really pissed
off at that point
anyway uh so we'll fix that because
over the long term scale with a lot of
people um
in the sample the down bear strategy
really ought to
do pretty good so anyway uh we'll hit
that in the next video probably so
anyways hopefully you guys enjoyed you
got your day allen bear strategy feel
free to play around maybe make your
waiter size one
if you want you can probably figure out
how to edit roll dice to make it 50 50
odds otherwise
wait for the next video as always thanks
for watching